expresa 25 grados celsius con una
temperatura en grados fahrenheit usando
la fórmula grados fahrenheit efe es
igual a 9 quintos por grados celsius más
32 nos están dando una temperatura de 25
grados celsius que podemos sustituir
enlace aquí para obtener el valor
correspondiente de temperatura en grados
fahrenheit hagamos eso tenemos que f es
igual a 9 quintos en vez de se vamos a
sustituir el valor de 25 por 25 y eso
más 32 podemos simplificar esto antes de
que multiplicamos 9 quintos por 25
recuerda que esto es lo mismo que 9
quintos por 25 entre 1 y ahora podemos
antes de hacer el producto dividir
numerador y denominador entre 5 así es
que en el numerador 25 entre 5 es igual
a 5 y en el numerador 5 entre 1 es igual
a 1 esto nos queda 9 por 5 más 32 así es
que los grados fahrenheit son igual a 9
por 545 más 32
efe es igual a 45 32 77 grados
así es que esto es 77 grados fahrenheit